I realized this week that I need
to build a tremendous legal team
to help me
with this investigation
that I'm totally not under.
Wink.
It's time for "Lawyering Up!"
(dramatic theme music playing)
(applause and cheering)
Well, Gloria,
I'd shake your hand, but
I don't want to get sued for
touching you inappropriately.
You would be.
I'm in a bit of trouble, Kuby.
I'm not gonna lie.
So I understand.
I am auditioning lawyers to be
on my legal team. First off,
how Jewy are you?
On a scale of one to Jerry,
are you, like, a four or a five?
'Cause we all know
Jewish lawyers
are the best.
I'm very Jewy.
Not very Jewy.
I don't even understand
that question.
See? There we go.
A coy Jew.
Now, you've defended
con artists,
foreign agents and mobsters,
but have you ever done
all three at once?
This would be my first
if I took the case.
-Triple Lindy.
-Yeah.
If I hired you,
-would I be your favorite
client? -First of all,
you'd be second
to O.J. Simpson...
-Love the guy.
-...Klaus von Bülow...
Great guy, too.
...Mike Tyson...
-Here we go.
-...and Bill Clinton?
-Bill Clinton?
-Yeah.
I don't think
that you remember me.
I have a-a lawsuit against you.
-What?
-On behalf of Summer Zervos,
-Oh, God.
-who is one of the women
that during
the presidential campaign...
Oh, wow. Is this the way
the interview's going?
...who accused you
of actually doing
some of the things
that you said...
-I object! -...you did
on that Access Hollywood tape.
-You're out of order!
-Where you alleged
you could grab a woman by...
I'm not going to use the word
that you said.
-Pussy.
-Genital, and
then you said they're liars.
-Yeah, liars.
-And I filed
a lawsuit against you
which is now pending
-in New York City.
-That's the kind of lawyer
-I want.
-I can't! It's a conflict.
You attended Yale Law School.
-I did. -And then,
you're a professor at Harvard.
-Mm-hmm. -What, you think
you're better than me?
Absolutely. I have no doubt
that I'm better than you.
Uh, you went
to University of Pennsylvania.
-Wharton. I went to Wharton.
-Fourth or fifth ranked.
-I went to Wharton. Please.
-I went to Yale Law School.
-Number one... school.
Harvard Law School. -Number one?
-Give me a break, Dershowitz.
-I am much better than you.
-But don't Dershowitz me.
-Don't you want a lawyer
-that's better than you?
-Don't Dershowitz me.
-You want a lawyer
that's worse than you? -Yes!
We have attorney-client
privilege, right?
-No, we don't.
-All right, I'm gonna
-admit some things to test it.
-I'm gonna
tell everybody everything
you've said here today.
Anything you tell me
is completely confidential.
-I could tell you anything?
-Anything.
I have a small heart attack
four times a day.
-Ah. Okay.
-I think
about Jeff Sessions in a bikini
all the time.
-Do you?
-I have
Rue McClanahan's brain in a jar.
Are you sure these are things
that I should know?
I want to hunt and eat
a male ballerina.
-Oh, my God.
-I masturbate with both hands.
Who-who... who doesn't?
Alan,
am I being investigated or not?
You are being investigated-ish.
-Uh, ish. -Is this Yiddish?
Are you speaking Yiddish?
I am speak...
(both speaking Yiddish)
Uh, yeah, yeah. Ish.
Eh, not quite investigated,
not quite not investigated.
But let's face it, around
The White House, it's mishegoss.
It is.
If I become your lawyer,
will you actually
do the things I suggest you do?
-No.
-Okay. Will you
stop doing the things
I suggest you stop doing?
No.
Okay. Thank you... for that.
What is my biggest
legal problem?
Did you ever hear these words?
-(loudly):
Obstruction of justice? -Ow!
No, I haven't heard them
till you said them.
Can I sue James Comey?
If you tried to get him
to stop investigating you...
I didn't do it.
That's potentially
obstruction of justice.
Ding! Ding! Ding!
-Did I win something?
-That is an impeachable offense!
-You can't handle the truth!
-(scoffs)
You don't know where I'm coming
from. I'm crazy like a fox.
'Cause it makes your job easier.
No, it makes my job better,
because
-if you get yourself indicted...
-Right.
-...or impeached,
I have a real job! -What?
And you're helping me
enormously.
Everything you say,
everything you do
makes it more likely
you're going to get impeached.
Resign now
while there's still time.
Do you think
you could keep me out of jail?
If you do
what I tell you to do...
-Yes. -...I can keep you
out of prison.
I'm not sure at this point
that-that I want to.
You know something? There's
a lot I'd like to do with you.
-And to you. -There's a lot
I'd like to do with you, too.
-It's all legal, though.
It's all... -Mine's all illegal.
-Really?
-Oh. Oh, boy, Gloria.
Don't do this to me.
You are so disgusting.
Thank you!
♪ ♪
Gloria,
let me tell you something.
I wish I could have you
on my legal team,
but you just
didn't represent yourself
with the knowledge of the body
of the law that's needed.
Unfortunately...
you haven't passed
the interview...
and you're fired.
♪ ♪
Kuby, though I think
you're smart,
you're ultimately
a dirty hippie.
I have to go with my gut.
You're fired.
♪ ♪
Alan Dershowitz,
unfortunately you're too Jewish
even for me.
You're fired.
♪ ♪
So I'm gonna have to go
to my back pocket
for my Trump card, so to speak.
Gilbert Gottfried...
you are my new lawyer.
Donald, I told you,
I'm not really a lawyer.
(whispers):
That's okay.
I'm not really a president.
(audience applause, whooping)